So do you ever wonder how a team
of heroes, a tight knit group,
can just completely fall apart?
Or we're going to look at
exactly that, an incredible
story of how a group of
adventurers, totally united in
purpose, were shattered in a
single afternoon.
So how does something like this
even happen?
Well, it all kicks off with a
little bit of indecision, a huge
missed opportunity, and a plan
that was, let's be honest, born
from pure desperation.
This is a perfect example of how
fast things can spiral out of
control.
All right, let's set the scene.
We're in this really tense town
called Valaki.
There's been a bloody festival,
a huge political shake up, and
our adventurers are trying to
figure out what to do next.
The whole town is on a knife's
edge, and frankly, so are they.
On top of all that, they're
stuck trying to figure out this
super cryptic tarot card reading
they got.
They solved a couple of the
clues, but the rest they're just
staring at them, totally
stumped.
They can't even agree on what
these fortunes are supposed to
mean.
And right in the middle of all
this confusion, it hits one of
them.
The rogue Damon.
He gets this awful sinking
feeling, That priceless wedding
dress they risk their necks for,
the one they stormed a mansion
to get.
It might have been sitting in a
simple cargo wagon this whole
time.
So they decide to ambush the
wagon.
Great plan, right?
Well, it falls apart
immediately.
They start bickering over every
little detail, getting lost in
all the what ifs.
And while they're arguing the
wagon, the whole reason for the
plan just rolls right by the
inn.
They don't even notice until the
innkeeper points it out.
OK, so Damon has had enough.
He is done talking.
He's not waiting around for
another debate.
He just leaps to his feet, bolts
out the door, and decides to
handle this himself.
And what follows is this chaotic
solo heist right through the
city streets.
And what he does next is, well,
it's both genius and completely
insane.
He catches up to the wagon,
scrambles underneath it, and
starts using his magic.
He creates the sound of a bear
to spook the horses, then uses a
magical hand to release the
brake.
The whole thing just takes off,
careening down the street.
Then, with another flick of that
magical hand, he locks the
brakes back up the wagon.
Just Jack knives.
It's a huge, violent crash, but
there, amidst all the wreckage
and the mud, he sees it.
The pristine wedding dress.
He actually pulled it off, but
that feeling of victory, It
lasts about two seconds because
he looks over and sees the
horses maimed and dying from the
crash.
His plan worked, but it came at
this terrible, brutal cost.
He's forced to put them out of
their misery himself before he
slips away into the shadows.
Now, while all of Damon's chaos
is going down on one side of
town, a totally different story
is just beginning.
A mysterious new person is
arriving in Valaki, and he has
absolutely no idea what he's
about to walk into.
Meet you're a horn, Tenpenny.
He's a halfling Beastmaster, and
he's traveled a long, long way
to get here.
He finds Valaki completely
locked down under a strict
curfew and has to bribe the
guards just to get in.
He's here for one reason, to
find allies to take down Straud
himself.
So where does he go for shelter?
The Blue Water Inn?
Yep, the very same in our heroes
just stormed out of.
And there he meets this really
charismatic entertainer, a guy
who calls himself Rick Tavio.
But it's pretty clear he's more
than just a simple circus
ringleader.
And this is Borovia, right?
So you know that nobody is ever
who they appear to be.
Rick Tavio invites him up to his
room for a private chat, and,
well, that's when everything
changes in the room.
The truth comes out.
Rick Tavio's whole appearance
just shimmers and the disguise
melts away.
He isn't some Vagabond
entertainer.
He's Rudolf Van Richten.
The Rudolf Van Richten, the
legendary Monster Hunter Yuri
Horn, is just standing there,
face to face with a living
legend.
But here's the kicker.
The first thing Van Richten does
is give him this chilling
warning about, you guessed it,
our heroes.
He tells You're a Horn to stay
away from them, claiming they've
helped vampires before He plants
this deep seed of mistrust, even
suggesting they could be spies
for Strawd.
And that seed of mistrust gets
planted at the worst possible
moment, because at that exact
same time, Damon's companions,
the cleric Tracer Door and the
knight Radley are showing up at
the crash site, and they are
walking straight into a trap.
They get to the scene looking
for their friend, but he's long
gone.
All they find is a wrecked wagon
and a really, really angry mob,
and the crowd immediately starts
pointing and shouting.
Those are the strangers the
Burgundistress is looking for.
Now look, these two guys,
they're elite warriors.
In a fair fight, they would wipe
the floor with anyone in that
crowd.
But this isn't a fair fight.
This is 2 against dozens of
furious people.
The numbers are just not on
their side.
The fight is over almost before
it starts.
It's just brutal.
They take a few people down with
them, sure, but they are just
completely overwhelmed by the
sheer weight of the mob.
They're beaten into the ground
and captured by the city guard.
So just like that, the party is
shattered.
Damon has the dress, but his
friends are now prisoners.
And the one potential ally who
just rode into town has been
told that the heroes themselves
are the real enemy here.
Which leaves us with a final,
really big question.
With their team completely
broken and two of their own in
chains, all because of 1 bad
plan, who's left to stand
against the darkness of this
land?